ha I think there are now 73 pockets of
resistance inside FIFA I think France
Prince Ali did very well today surprised
me that he got that amount of votes so I
think that's a good sign but I think
people have more to fear from the
Department of Justice and the Federal
Bureau of Investigation than anything
inside FIFA step ladder has delivered
money to countries outside Europe for
football in Africa and Asia they appear
to have voted for him is there anything
inherently corrupt about that do you
think well no there's not i mean i
traveled the world investigating
match-fixing with fever and i've seen
and visited a lot of those football
associations who are absolutely in
abject poverty and real i desperately on
on FIFA money and what people have tried
to do by moving a lot of the wealth to
the poorer nations and associations is a
good thing it's just that the way
they've done it is not okay do you think
there's anything wrong with that
relationship because that appears to be
how he survives yeah I think that's
that's a really crucial part of house at
blossom is secure ree coronation up to
read coronation it's not just that he
turns a blind eye to the rampant
corruption in a rank-and-file of FIFA
but it's also that he he insecure he
kind of has this patronage relationship
where he does by favor and he has access
to FIFA's vast coffers they've got 1.5
billion dollars in cash reserves and and
he can dole out that money in gold
program funding and I think that's part
of the reason why actually there is a
culture of vote-buying in seaford that
actually anyone who goes up against set
slicer like Mohammed bin hammam from
Qatar did in 2011 has enough to contend
with he has also financial firepower the
organization and other people then feel
they need to offer favors as well I mean
there's so much money involved with
sponsorship and with host nations can he
legitimately say look I don't know
what's going on with this I'm just doing
my job organizing World Cups I think it
beggars belief that in embarking on his
fifth term in office that he really
isn't aware of the fact that he's
presiding over one of the world's most
rampantly Corrupt Organizations I mean
he
he has to know what's going on and where
the bodies are buried and I think that
is part of the reason he survives that
that he is protecting a lot of people
who have a lot to hide mrs. thing from
your knowledge of FIFA do you think
that's fair one of the world's most
rapidly Corrupt Organizations book yeah
I mean it's documented now isn't it over
the last 17 years its corruption scandal
after corruption scandal I think that
mr. Blatter is but at the helm of his
boat for that time and it's either gross
competence negligence or mismanagement
but to say that he's not aware that any
of its going on well many a corporate
leader would have been removed way
before this where do you think the Ross
is the corruption is where is it within
the structure of organizing world
football where is it with inside FIFA I
think he starts at the top I mean let's
not forget that inside the house of joy
at Zurich there are 300 people that work
just like you and I do day after day for
the good of FIFA they're not involved in
any of this at all in fact the analogy
would be there are a lot of like a
football club that changes ownership for
instance does it affect the players know
they go out and do the job what happens
in the boardroom doesn't affect them and
it's the same with FIFA the people that
put on World Cup after world cup and do
a fantastic job I really tainted by
those at the top the fact they they have
access to the contract to the sponsors
they're in a position where they can
actually be a part of deals and take
money I mean you must feel that that is
a bit like Rasputin you know no matter
what he's stabbing poisoning whatever he
still carries on going is there a way it
can further investigation bring an end
to this do you think i mean i think the
involvement of the FBI is a game changer
personally i think i think that you know
it's speeding to assembly quite close to
Michael Garcia FIFA's internal
investigator who had such difficulty
actually trying to a suggestion he
fudged it rather there is a suggestion
he fudged it and I think he could have
been more assiduous but I also think
that you know he did have some evidence
in his report which FIFA was very keen
to Boulder eyes and cover up and i SPECT
with someone close
he was saying that they really feel that
now the Swiss prosecutors were involved
and they have powers of subpoena that
might really blow open some of the dead
ends that they encountered but then the
FBI have now you know brought in these
seven officials who will know an awful
lot about what's been going on inside
world football and if they can get those
people to flip and start talking the way
they've got Chuck blazer they form a US
official to start talking then really
that things might start to come out and
that could change things okay I believe
you there thank you both very much
indeed